economía en directo América de France 24
Juan Pablo lucumí nuevamente con
nosotros en el estudio Juan Pablo Buen
día vamos a comenzar con el informe de
las perspectivas económicas del Banco
Mundial que según ellos mismos golpea
con fuerza a los países en desarrollo
Así es Raúl buenos días hay recortes
generales de las proyecciones se espera
que la economía global crezca solo un
1,7% en 2023 del 3% que se había
pronosticado seis meses atrás las
previsiones son a la baja para casi
todas las economías avanzadas y casi del
70% para los mercados emergentes y en
desarrollo y mientras vemos Cuáles son
las proyecciones para América Latina y
el Caribe en pantalla traigo a colación
las palabras del presidente del grupo
Banco Mundial quien dijo que abro
comillas los países emergentes y en
desarrollo se enfrentan a periodos de
varios años de crecimiento lento
impulsados por una pesada carga de las
deudas y escasas inversiones cierro
comillas América Latina y el Caribe
creció un 3,6% el año pasado y Espera
que el crecimiento de este año sea tan
solo del 1,3% para pasar a recuperarse
un poco en el 2024 hasta el
2,4%. el organismo advierte que dadas
las frágiles condiciones económicas
cualquier acontecimiento adverso una
fuerte inflación aumento brusco de los
tipos de interés un rebrote de la
pandemia o aumente las en las tensiones
geopolíticas podría ser el detonante
para que la economía mundial entre en
recesión el banco aseguró que de suceder
así sería la primera vez en 80 años que
dos recesiones globales ocurren en la
misma década bueno Juan Pablo vamos a
hablar ahora de la segunda economía de
la zona Euro es Francia porque tenía un
panorama complicado a nivel económico un
escenario difícil que las autoridades
económicas dicen que pese a todo esto
está resistiendo mejor de lo esperado
recordemos que el final del año pasado
en la economía francesa tuvo que
enfrentar las huelgas de refinerías en
octubre la polémica del presupuesto que
presentó en la primera ministra en ese
mismo mes y la de algunas plantas
nucleares que volvieron a funcionar con
todo esto El Banco Central europeo dijo
este miércoles que la economía de
Francia creció
0,1% en el último trimestre de 2022 con
respecto al mismo periodo del 2021 pero
advirtió que pudo haber sido mucho peor
hablemos ahora de la Cumbre de los
líderes de América del Norte que en qué
llegaron Juan Pablo a las conclusiones
económicas pues es algo que lo que están
de acuerdo los tres estados unidos
Canadá y México es que el objetivo de la
Cumbre es que Norteamérica sea la región
económica más competitiva próspera y
resistente del mundo quien reducir la
dependencia del resto del mundo algo que
ha enfatizado Joe biden con su
pronóstico o con su propósito mejor de
la fabricación de semiconductores en
esta parte del mundo y algo de lo que
Andrés Manuel López Obrador también ha
hablado y ha criticado también que hay
demandas y de importaciones Hay
demasiadas importaciones de Europa y de
Asia en Norteamérica Esto fue lo que
dijo que acordamos fortalecer nuestras
relaciones económicas y comerciales
para lo cual se creará
un comité conjunto
destinado a la planeación
y a
la sustitución de importaciones en
América del Norte
procurar ser cada vez más
autosuficientes un tema controversial en
materia económica que quedó por fuera de
las agendas es la política energética
que pretende implementar el gobierno del
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
en México y que ha sido motivo de
disputa con sus socios del temec Canadá
y Estados Unidos acusan a López Obrador
de violar un pacto de libre comercio al
favorecer a la empresa Estatal mexicana
frente a las centrales eléctricas
construidas por inversores extranjeros y
privados Juan Pablo mi indicadores
económicos Y empezamos con Estados
Unidos porque Wall Street fue positivo
toda la apertura con la esperanza de que
las cifras de inflación y ganancias de
Estados Unidos que se conocerán este
jueves apunten a una economía resistente
y un ritmo más lento de aumento de las
tasas de interés Juan Pablo gracias a
como siempre por toda la información
económica mañana con más así es mañana
con más mañana con más y nosotros
volamos directo hasta París ahí nos está
esperando nuestro periodista
Luis Miguel Cabrera